hey how you doing this is Maul this is
Rory from the new Rory Mall podcast and
we're here to ask the internet answer
the internet but a lot of people say yes
all right [__] it this is Baisley if you
could get [__] faced with any come on
they're gonna ask me this
if you can get [__] faced with any U.S
president who would it be oh the Teflon
dog baby
oh my God absolutely uh I think I'm
gonna go JFK he had the hose man yeah
yeah I feel like he wasn't someone that
was he was a proper ladies oh for sure
and he didn't look like he was
possessive like he would have passed
Maryland off I feel like even though
this is my man yeah
you want to talk about puck bunnies he
probably had all his Boston [__] sure
what he went crazy that's why he got
killed it was somebody's husband
would you date your dream girl if for
two days every week your choice she had
to dress like a juggalo what's a juggalo
the Insane Clown Posse black and white
okay all that [__] I don't know man I'm
getting into my 30s I might be into that
that might be a plus yeah
two days a week that's making five
everything I did in my 20s I'm kind of
over like let's let's throw in some kiss
makeup and go no are you going out with
the girls tonight it's Juggalo night
dress like a juggler yeah that's how you
that's how you that's how you fix that
what about uh what about if you had to
go to the Juggalo
festival or whatever they call it
Festival of clowns yeah I'm with it yeah
I get to do that too
that probably is a trip that's probably
an experience I don't know it's a good
one or a bad one but it's certainly it's
one yeah replicated sign me up what is
the fiercest animal you think you could
take in a fight the fierce this is for
sure I probably I'd kick a flamingo's
ass I think I think I could take a
flamingo I would hope right I think I
could kick it from that one leg out yeah
Birds I don't [__] with birds too they
go like they get to pecking at you yeah
yeah yeah I really don't have a fear of
pit bulls like that if they latch onto
my arm I think with the adrenaline if
you give me my left I'm going Cranium
non-stop I think I could take you could
take a pit bull you think if it just
latched if it like if it went nuts I'm
chilling what do you think about the
pitbulls that are like Suburban pits
like a project pit bull I don't know if
you know what a project pit bull like
they eat Pepsi cans it's on Section
Eight yeah it gets government assistance
yeah I don't think you want to see that
see one of those it only gets dog food
we were talking on our podcast uh was it
gorilla 50 men versus one gorilla bro
100 men we've done all this [__] before
will [__] run your [__] I think you
need like a thousand men dude if we're
talking like they don't have any weapons
or anything just bear fists yeah like
because the problem is you could even
maybe like get to it and hold it down
but to kill it like to make it like it's
always just gonna eventually get back up
and just start [__] rocking you I
just does it have allergies like let's
find another strategy does have high
blood pressure what do we we have one I
don't have a car this one but it was
every time you get it get in and out of
your car there's a like a swarm of
chickens in your car or you gotta fight
a gorilla once a year on pay-per-view
and I think you get a sword you're good
at a sword do I get it do I get
pay-per-view money like yeah
you get the Floyd cut yeah but yeah I'm
taking the sword yeah but I mean you
might you might like that gorilla might
kill you you're gonna risk your life
sword I mean you might have a sword do
you know have you ever used a sword
so it's basically the same thing right
um I don't I don't think my anxiety
could take getting in my car which every
time
you try to take somebody in your car
you're on a date you have a company do
whatever Ducks everywhere yeah
maybe I'm just on the A train for the
rest of my life
would you rather bang a bunch of models
but nobody knows or not actually [__]
them but have everyone think you did
well I do want to [__] them so
and I actually hope no one knows Yeah
well yeah I mean I guess if that's your
mindset but like you look at you know
Pete Davis has got himself a career just
from people thank you thinking I mean it
sounds like he does but maybe who knows
maybe he doesn't he might be the first
one he keep banging him if you're known
as the guy who [__] all the hottest
chicks you have like a career off of
that yeah that's that's the choice but
I'd rather [__] them and nobody knows
yeah yeah I'm taking that one yeah I
won't take I won't take the core side
seats
just because he maybe is [__] uh
whatever two buttons you can only press
one hey instantly get a million dollars
or B have a 50 50 chance you get 100
million dollars
how risky are you boys
some buttons if you live in New York a
million dollars is not what you think I
ain't gonna do [__] for you so give me
the beat 50 50 chance at 100 million
yeah I'm gonna go with B2 I I mean I'm
in some steep issues with the IRS right
now a million dollars I'm gonna take the
risk for that 100 yeah yeah the
million's not gonna do much for me we're
on the run right now what do we got the
Ronaldo
listen you know I thought it was a
suggestions yeah sometimes this podcast
money exactly it's so funny I'll take
I'll take B 50 50 chance football how
high would a need to be for you to to
take out take the guarantee yeah
or I'd have to figure out what the tax
code is that you get to that percent
where you can lie on your taxes and
don't five mil they might actually tax
me right
Rich yeah yeah absolutely would you
rather win a Little League World Series
title or be a Triple A baseball player
who will never get called up
nah man give me the Little League World
Series title man it's all about the
trophies what's your mass in the Bronx
that was like 25. uh Danny Daniel Legend
we know his name right I can't name him
AAA ball player that didn't go to the
MLB you win a you win a Little League
World Series as you know like 12 12 13
or whatever that changes you you you
walk around [__] especially now
yeah you you yeah you could be famous
the next day absolutely and who knows
what college athletes making money now
you get rich you might get this 12 year
olds meanwhile money is like they they
just uh renegotiated yeah and I think
AAA guys make like 22 000 a year it's
like it's like literally not even you
can't live on it one time my dad took me
to a Norwich Navigators game yeah barely
remember yeah
now Danny Almonte
after that we'll never forget him would
you rather have your internet history
made public or a sex tape that goes
viral oh man virus I got a sex tape let
me tell you something every day I
contemplate putting that on the line
she's a [__] IG Vixen yeah I don't
know man
the first one would be less uh
underwhelming I feel like my sex tape
wouldn't wouldn't really get the clicks
the way that maybe my browser history
sometimes you get okay this guy's kind
of [__] up but he's really loose in
the browser right like it's not even
sometimes not even sex stuff it's just
weird [__] that I'm Googling yeah
there'd be more Reddit comments off my
internet browser history than any of my
boring missionaries I just love the fact
that 69 of bar stool readers chosen
section
that's a fact what's the youngest age
child that could beat you up
the youngest I mean who's the kid Danny
Almonte so that's the problem though so
that's that's the questions like
there are some [__] 10 year olds over
in Russia who are beating up a tree
training to be a [__] MMA fighter who
could probably run my [__] yeah I don't
know especially with like the steroids
that they put in the chicken now it's
not the chicken I grew up on yeah a
nine-year-old Mikey that's what I mean
like you get the right nine-year-old
he's put me at like an alarm bar I'm
tapping out yeah easily wait don't break
my [__] off please don't don't do
that and you can like maybe 11 12
depending on what like
like not a lot of them but we're talking
the whole world like there's one of them
there's two of them there's a couple out
there oh [__] your [__] and like I
didn't have the internet where I could
study [__] Tai Chi and become a black
belt from my crib right yeah no these
kids
YouTube That's training like mixed
martial arts right now they're probably
they will [__] you up
if every time you finish sex a song
played what song would you want it to be
uh Reuben Studdard sorry for 2004.
um mines would probably be um what's the
guy that just passed away a legendary
songwriter a lovely day
Bill Withers Lovely Day yeah she better
be pregnant
with us man she's a great I think that
song Fits everything but play a little
bit you can't I love that it's got to be
fixed yeah it has to be you pulling out
with Bill playing after no you're
leaving that in even if you wanted to if
you leave it yeah
and the whole year of 2004.
that was the sickest song ever
the song came out in 2004 it wasn't done
bro this is some funny [__] questions
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out